okay hello everyone
welcome to another software design
discussion
part of our incremental language
development series
about future versions of orphan language
and i think first up
minimal tree design
oh wow okay do i run this code or not uh
you don't need to run the code but if
you'd like to play with the examples you
can run the code to play with it
okay so we've got lots of things going
on here okay
that looks pretty nice
that's a
that's a a random tree
without labels
yep
i believe in ian you can correct me if
i'm wrong here but the specific that
we're looking at here is the unlabeled
tree design
if you're talking we can't hear you
we need in for this so if n is somehow
we should go on to the next item and
come back to this
okay yeah we can start talking about the
next item and then whenever ian's here
we can look at it
can somebody message him please we can
yes i'll message him
he is here but he must be having you
hear me
okay now we can hear you sorry
okay
all right explain
so we're dealing with the unlabeled tree
we've got an unlabeled tree the literal
function unlabeled tree what should the
output look like okay so what what
you're showing us here
is what unlabeled tree wrapped around
random tree of 12 should look like that
point
yeah
okay and so those node sizes we have
some method for dealing with absolute
versus non
node sizes in ordinary graphs i mean i
would assume this should look the same
albeit with different colors
i mean if i do this as a graph right so
i say random tree 15 or something and
then i say
gra
tree graph
of this
okay so the differences here
are
you've got gray as opposed to blue
yeah we're comparing these two things
right
is that correct
i suppose
how could it not be i mean
you know
we've worked on the design of graphs
so now we want something for the design
of trees
i mean
what what am i missing here
i mean this
in this case we are we have much
thinner
narrower connections here because we are
using the fact that the very placement
of things in the tree is an important
part of the information content is that
correct
i i'm not sure that's just a thickness
of one
from the original design spec it
shouldn't be a thickness one watt
pixel i think well that's no good that
won't work if we print it it will go
away
one pixel you cannot do that
okay
who's been paying attention to this that
doesn't
that doesn't work
go ahead we're gonna say well well can
you can you do tree graph of percent so
we rather than re-evaluating and so we
get a different
right so those are much thicker lines
okay if that's one pixel it is a bug
it so it's absolute thickness of one
which is one point it's not one it's not
it's not one pixel
is that right do we think
billy i i presume i presume that's the
spec right i mean we we got a spec from
design and
which i produce which i presume is what
yeah and this is an absolute thickness
of some kind so there's the graphs are
the same right
what do you mean
like graphs of the you know yeah right
if it's if it's one pixel thick it'll be
the same with graphs and trees
right well it should be but i don't know
whether it doesn't look it
it looks like three pixels or something
three points or something right but i
mean it's the same idea
right but does somebody know what it is
for graphs
unless charles is here i don't think
anybody knows what what what the default
is graph right but of course i mean we
don't write i mean
not that there shouldn't be similarities
between trees and graphs
right i mean in fact and the argument
should be that by default they shouldn't
be identical right so that you
uh can yeah tell them
but things like the thickness of the
lines is not the place where they should
be non-identical unless there's a good
reason for it
could we see if we can reach do you
think charles is the right person to
answer this question
charles would be the correct person to
answer this question
i mean we could in principle let me just
see just for the hell of it
does that give us information or does it
not
bezier curve
opacity seven
i think this is the default
i'm not seeing anything here that's
setting line thickness
well
let's see if we can can we see if we can
find charles
and ask him yes
um okay
i'm not wild about the hugeness of those
um
of those nodes
um up here i mean i rather like the look
of this tree
i'm not complaining about this i'm just
not super happy about its
incompatibility with what we're doing
with graphs
so what do other people think about that
tree
i mean the other thing we're doing here
is those are solid blocks
as opposed to what we're doing here
which is to have
you know a rim
can somebody comment who is sorry i
think there is i think there is i think
there is room there just hard to tell
um okay it's a little bit yeah it's a
little bit thin but maybe once we sync
up the the two thicknesses of the
edges we'll be able to see it a little
bit
uh better if that's inheriting the edge
thickness for the rim
but
we better figure out i mean is this the
do you believe this is the same size as
for graphs
uh yeah i wasn't sure either when i was
uh listening okay so we got to figure
that out i mean same size of the nodes
being the same size
i mean i i don't mind the look of this i
think this looks pretty decent
actually in some ways it looks better
than what the graph looks like
okay but let's take a look at the other
things your
no
i don't think we should do that
anybody else want to comment on that
we kind of liked how it looked like a
little spindle oh sorry sorry i was i i
was muted i mean right there are several
alternatives being presented here so
maybe rather than going into a detailed
discussion we should look at the survey
and then okay fine but these are all
alternatives they're not just different
cases
correct
those diamond things down below
alternatives are they part of the same
thing i wasn't sure so if you scroll
down a little bit
you know if i might comment you've got
the same alternative
right so so this is
keeping the the distinction of shapes
based on whether the children is none or
a list like the heck is this
what what ian just said maybe you should
listen to yes so in in the labeled tree
case we distinguish between leaves and
non-leaves okay by having square or
rounded
uh
rounded rectangles
right and it has nothing to do with the
label that's strictly a property of the
tree children
so there's an argument that unlabeled
tree
should
also have different shapes for these
things
so hold on so here are node how can it
be a leaf am i confused somehow
i'm saying you can have an exterior node
that's not a leaf i see i see i see
because it is not a leaf because it has
no children but it isn't a leaf now yeah
if you have an empty list or an empty
association
is that really a distinction that we
make elsewhere like does tree leaves not
include those
in 13 1 yeah
i mean
so this is what like if we just kind of
project this to a graph
and have all the same nodes
then then that will be this case here
you're losing more information than just
the labels i guess
because those null non-leaves
the null children non-leaves
the symbol none versus a list or an
association
[Music]
right none is a genuine leaf
oh
so i don't know i mean maybe
i'm sorry i see
like at the very bottom there's like a
square but above that it's
a
i'm guessing this has to be wrong this
this i just don't know squares can only
be exterior nodes
but exterior nodes can also be circles
or diamonds
just like internet what is a diamond an
association
right so currently
association and list are just both
rounded rectangles so this is an idea to
split off association
into a third shape i feel like
associations it seems like associations
the thing to make a distinction on would
be edges coming out of it as opposed to
the note itself right because it's
basically like i mean
correct me if i'm wrong but i thought
associations were for sort of labeled
edges as opposed to uh
unlabeled ones yes especially indexed
edges
yes that's correct as opposed to
positionally indexed edges
that's correct
so in other words the part specification
on a tree would have an association key
as opposed to a positional number yep
right right but it seems like then the
thing to do would be to label the edge
or to somehow annotate the edge coming
out of that node
so the default edge label is the key
no i understand but what christopher
already does that i see so it already
labels them yeah and and just a minor
point that's maybe not so important is
you know what if you have an empty
association then you don't have any
edges coming out to style
yeah sure yeah
i feel like the association case is
probably i mean if the only case where
it's actually ambiguous
is uh
is is when it's uh sort of one of these
empty
empty
non leaves that i think that's kind of a
an edge case
so to speak
jose has suggested it that it's
it might be a good idea to have some
sort of like partial stem coming out of
in such a case
but we haven't come up with the design
for that
i think it's an unusual case to have a a
childless
non-leaf
and i agree that that's a nice notation
for a childness non-leaf
would be a
a little stub of a stem
that doesn't go anywhere
well
having something there kind of no
because there's a one like there's one
of it which seems wrong
it's zero of it
i don't know what do people think about
the use case for the childless non-leaf
it
is essential and it's the thing that
allowed us to actually support things
like xml
in this version
[Music]
because you can have a tag with no
uh contents and that's different from
just text
right i mean right right that's the
right that's the f of bracket bracket
case right i mean that that is an
important
yeah and we were we were doing some
clever hacks before in order to make
expression tree work
in those cases before i mean otherwise
what you do is you just say that f open
close is is a there's a whole leaf
right which i you know
that's that's not great but no it is
doable
yeah it's doable and we did it and now
we have a much cleaner design
with this empty list all right so
conceptually
this says
it has all of the tagging of being a
head
it just doesn't happen to have any
arguments
correct it's a zero length head
or zero length
right expression zero arguments not wild
about the squares as the
end point i don't know what makes it you
know there doesn't seem to be any
endiness to a square
if that makes any sense right yeah and
as in a in the sense it seems wrong
right it seems i mean or right the fact
that it seems on some level it seems
like the circle
i see sticking with these three symbols
it seems like the circle should be the
leaf given that
the
you know circle and diamond both have
children
right now right so you'd think that the
two things that have children's should
be
more similar
on the other hand diamonds look more
leaf-like
yeah
i guess you look at the labeled case
where we
uh
maybe we need to use uh the
clover character for the leaves
um right
get some bark texture on the on the
edges
oh i guess we don't have an actual
i guess with the cloverleaf character
that we have is actually the command
symbol but um
you know
this doesn't look bad
right so my point is like rounded
rectangles correspond to the circles
it's just if you have a label it becomes
a rounded rectangle instead of a circle
and so if we invert that then we would
have most of the thing being
rectangles and then the leaves being
rounded rectangles
this is quite nice
so let's understand how we
i personally think that the distinction
between the rounded and square is
important the one that i'm not sure is
the diamond
no i don't think i think it's a real i
don't think we should do that
yeah the diamond i think perhaps it
should be something that you can obtain
with some string value somewhere but not
by default
yeah
i agree is this a different green did we
go more
camouflage or something here
it's to match the uh
unlabeled version so if you go and look
at original down below also
it's like much lighter before
yeah
so so this was to address the concern if
instead of using unlabeled tree you'd do
like a tree map of no on the whole tree
it was way too faint
because why
um
so i'm i'm confused by that so
so can you do like tree map
null over a random tree
no ampersand
yeah that's pretty ghostly
look
we got to find a way
i think this is too dark
well i don't know what do other people
think
i think having a default background
is not great
because i can imagine all kinds of weird
cases where you've got a color in that
you know in the in the node and it's it
looks really ugly with that background
and so on and so on and so on
i think the green is a little bit
is the slightly
you know uh
old-school
terminal looking
but
yeah especially with the square
characters
um
okay something a little bit lighter back
there yeah but but what about the
possibility of darkening the border when
the things i mean in other words if what
we're trying to do what about darkening
the border but not darkening the
interior
yeah the only the only issue that might
come up is those abc on the on those
connecting lines if they get darker as
well but if what can't talk if the
connecting lines get darker
yeah well why are those abcs is that an
edge label is that a graph edge label
does it sit now that's because there's
an association there no no i know that
but i mean in terms of when you have a
graph label an edge label in a graph
doesn't it sit to the side of the edge
right that's the default edge label
placement
this one here
okay so if that's working for ordinary
graphs
with that darkness level
and maybe it doesn't work well for that
and by the way
now that we have um this kind of drop
shadow technology maybe we should be
using that for a bunch more of these
labels charles do you have a comment on
that
as the creator of both the labels and
the drop shadow
um yes we were experimenting and you
know
and we hope that when you register i
mean there is a performance issue we are
working on in terms of drop shadow so it
you know you can have
a thousand of them in a page but yes
there was by the way there was a
question earlier about what thickness
line thickness are the edges using by
the fault is that just the normal graph
whatever the the fault of graphics
that's what we want to know yeah that's
the default line
thickness
okay
maybe a little thick
but okay we should do the same thing for
trees i can't see any argument from not
doing the same thing for trees
but now you have a nonzero you know you
have a non one opacity for these right
um
yes if i
i don't remember we have opacity i i
just looked onside it was like 0.7 yes
there is one
so i suspect that's what we should do
for trees as well even though for trees
we know that there won't be the same
kind of overlap issue as there is for
graphs
i mean basically visually the trees are
going to look more like graphs but the
only distinction is going to be you know
the shape of the vertices i guess and
then the color
yeah the color the greeniness
also when you click them
graphics purple trees are green i know
sure yeah and i guess also the edges are
don't have uh arrows and i mean they
don't always have arrows in the graph
either but yeah
right
so
and the fact that
i mean
i don't know whether we should be
looking because i'm not wild about the
way that this graph looks here it's
certainly better than those crazy brown
ones from a few versions ago but it's
possible that we should try and re-up
this again as well
comments charles any
comments um yes i agree it's something
we have been considering actually you
know
another pass of looking at the way craft
look i mean we built that 10 years ago i
mean things look we can make it look
better
we should do it we should get a meeting
with design about that but then okay so
look for trees i think we should try and
follow graphs more closely and if we you
know maybe trees will lead because i i
personally i like the look of these
nodes better than i like the look of
these nodes
well i mean it seems like i mean hold on
if we're gonna if we're gonna change the
styling for graph
i mean my guess looking at the current
graph is that uh
i mean is that probably the changes are
gonna be like make it a bit lighter
weight like you know
bit
lighter in which case making trees a lot
darker to match the current graph seems
wrong stupid yeah right
well fine maybe trees should lead the
way for a new
look
another thing just just to mention but
at least for graphs i don't know about
trees but at least for graphs it seems
like the default styling should should
probably also be you know
performance informed because i think
sometimes you know when you have really
big graphs it can be a problem
yep
well okay
what do you think do you think we should
leave the absolute thickness one thing
here even though that's different from
graphs
comments from people
on the ground that that might be the
future of graph itself
i mean i don't know i i don't i don't
have much of a problem with it being
that thin i think you can easily see it
i mean i guess trees are a bit easier
too because the edges are in predictable
places like you could you could
basically not draw the edges and still
know what's going on which is not true
for graphs
right i i think yeah and i think the
um i mean i guess i i like the trees
thin uh i'm not sure how much thinner we
can make graphs because right with
graphs you can also have curves and
you know you can have more more
interesting
edges than you can with trees
right okay fine well then
okay then let's assume we're okay with
this do we think we're okay with this
look
for this random tree so then if we move
that down so that means is this the same
thickness here
with the labeled tree
i think so
do we like the look of this i mean again
we think we're going to have to go less
ghostly for the notes because we've gone
much less ghostly here
and then is this
is this darker
green here the one that matches
that darkened look no it isn't it's
different it looks different here that
is not the same as the unlabeled tree
look
right
yeah
so what are we doing here
you know if we have a labeled tree which
happens to have unlabeled edges do we
want it to look different from the
purely unlabeled tree
i would argue they should look the same
because if the thing that's
distinguishing trees from things like
grass is the color
then all trees should be that color by
default
okay
so i think we can cheat greatly in terms
of lightening up the background of these
big ones
and still keeping it dark in these small
ones
you're saying that if the tree happens
to not have a label that it will
render the same as unlabeled tree by
default
that will be the suggestion yes
is there a problem with that
i mean so right now all of the nodes are
using the same style
and i don't know how that behavior would
interact with style options yeah you
know what we can't make that work right
because it i i'm telling you you're
going to have to cheat for an unlabeled
node it's going to have a different
styling than a labeled node
just that's going to be necessary from a
graphic design point of view
you can't make it work it won't work
when you have a big area here if you
darken it to the point that you need to
darken it to get one of these to work
it's going to look stupid
get what i'm saying
i mean so what i'm saying is like if the
no if the unlabeled nodes are filled
what happens if you specify red for that
node
are you getting some darker red
or does it just become red just becomes
red
what happens in a graph
it's the same thing you just overwrite
it don't you vertex style just override
graph by default doesn't have two
different colored nodes
it doesn't matter this is the this is
the generic another thing you do
overwrites this
that would be my point of view
if i color the nodes in a graph here
um i get the whole node including its
it's its border right you can use this
form to affect the board i know you can
use edge form but without edge form the
whole node just becomes red
right so correct charles
so here if i say graph
of that comma
vertex style
one arrow red
oh gosh that's because what are the node
names
here what the heck are the node names
here
they're like
just do blank
okay so what happened there is as you
can see
the edge form did not by default get
changed
is that correct
the inner the filling of the
macaroon or whatever it is i don't know
what you know got changed out but the
crust did not
do i'm saying
so we should have the same behavior for
tree
i can't quite see but is the edge just
basically black or gray or is it
actually blue on the graphs
i'm not sure do you really know
let's see we can just make this
it's absolute thickness no so there it
looks
so there is there is an edge form
which is grey level zeros is black with
opacity
with opacity
and so that's why we're seeing this not
coming out as black
so it's black but with opacity i think
that's the right thing to do though
because it just means that
you know if it's black it's not going to
be much of a problem if you set the
vertex color to something weird
i agree so i think we should emulate
that for trees
so one possibility is to go with i don't
know what this edge color is here
to go with black the lowest opacity
making sense
yep
um
okay so what are we doing here so we got
to solve the technical problem of i mean
for this version we could just say
unlabeled trees do one thing and label
trees with unlabeled nodes do a
different thing
but what are we what are we what are we
expecting there
this doesn't work this isn't right
so for the unlabeled tree case are you
fine with the colors from above
the filled nodes they're dark green
i'm okay
and do we
want the
the squares and circles
i think we don't i think they're
adorable
by default no we don't want the diamonds
i think for the unlabeled tree we should
punt on the squares
that's what i think
i think you're rarely going to want to
because the case i'm sorry everything in
circles yes
okay
and then for the labeled k tree case
because a lot of the labeled nodes have
these rounded wrecked squares i think
we're good with squares
okay so the only thing that i see as a
problem is this needs to be lighter
maybe not should it just be the original
yeah but it could have a darker border i
don't know whether that what that would
look like
but this has a thicker that
line is darker which is probably good
and then that border and then the light
interior
am i making sense
but then this i think should darken up a
bit
go even darker than this
at the at the minimal size
make sense
yeah
okay can we try it but maybe we can wrap
back to this later in this meeting
make sense
can we move on
any further things on trees though
no
okay
disjoint intersecting queue subset queue
operator form yep so these are three
functions we touched earlier in thirteen
one um
we were in the process of documenting
them and we noticed they hadn't been
reviewed and specifically there's a
question about the operator form of
subset queue
which argument should be
in the operator form because with
disjoint q and intersecting q they're
symmetrical it doesn't matter if it's
the first or second argument but with
subset q it obviously does matter
um or do they even need the operator for
us
danny it's probably you um
uh
sorry say that again about
i mean i'm a little bit
yeah you're saying why do they need
operative forms that's what i just said
yeah
i think the operative forms are
confusing because you you're never going
to know which argument is is
you're saying it doesn't matter they
might as well be curried
right you're saying it just doesn't
matter which order it is it's as if
currying yeah for disjoint q and
intersecting q it doesn't matter so wait
wait but hold on shouldn't intersecting
q be
their arms i mean maybe it isn't but you
might imagine it would be
and if it were then there shouldn't be
an operator form it should just always
return i don't know true
i mean the these functions are not new
in thirteen one i think the
the same test queue option being added
and the operator forms being added are
new
and right but we've only defined
intersecting queue to argument form
right but in the section it's verox
right right and it seems useful for it
to be bearables i think one day it could
be bear args in which case we shouldn't
give an operator form yeah i agree what
what will it mean
um
do they all intersect or do pairs
intersect i think it's just checking if
length of intersection is greater than
zero
yes okay because um
although it's not on this list it
probably should be we do have unique
elements
which
can be used to
uh
does that does that work
does that give true or false or is that
just the same no but intersection right
well right but intersection can also be
straight i mean why do why did we need
intersecting q to begin with and the
answer is tally um is the short answer
um
but yeah i mean i agree it's sort of
useful
it's a somewhat useful idiom to say just
intersecting cube rather than
intersections naughty same q
empty list but
i'm just expressing doubt that we need
to make it var that's all i'm not saying
we absolutely can't but i don't know
okay
but but also this pairwise
i mean it's like unsame queue which is
all distinct
yeah
right but i should say
these functions have been
have had an operator form for several
versions it's just that we've never
documented them
and so
there was a note in the documentation
saying that intersecting you should
should leave our arc and so it it has to
be one or the other
so that's a decision to make here
i think we should do nothing i think we
should neither i don't think we have a
strong opinion either way i think we
don't have i think we should do nothing
i think we should neither make it fair
args nor make it give it an operative
form should we remove the operator form
or just not document it
i somewhat think we should remove it
now
doesn't contains queue contains q has an
operator form
yes
do you mean member queue
oh member queue definitely has an
operative form
is it is it only string contains q
no we have the whole five members
this contains any i don't remember a
contains right contains any contains all
contains only contains exactly
okay
although in a sense i feel like this is
more obvious right it's does
the operator form is does whatever i eat
contain the thing that's contained in
the operator form
whereas subset q i think is a bit more
confusing
yeah
i don't think maybe subsec q maybe we
can just think of it as i mean we have
these contains functions that already
have nice operator forms subset q is
identical to what would be contains all
or uh
something like that it contains only or
one of those and so maybe subsequent
should just be a more rigorous kind of
uh
argument function i kind of think so i
don't think we should have these
operative forms
same test option i don't have any
problem with that seems like a good idea
to me okay same test stays operator
forms go i think so yep we have had them
a while but all right
well i guess we'll find out if anybody's
been using them
true
um i would like to make a brief
statement which is jose and i put in
basic documentation not just for delete
elements but also for unique elements
and um
whatever the other one is symmetric
difference so yeah we might you might
want to review that just so that we can
yeah we know for sure that it's green
lit and can be put into the main
release branch
unique
what's the difference unique elements
what's the difference between unique
elements and delete duplicates
well that is my first question as well
but right i think it's like uh oh it's
unique elements across multiple
yeah find the ones that are unique to
each list
sub sub whatever it was at one point
called all compliments
so it's the complement of each list
against the other lists
against
presume
i'm not wild about the name unique
elements
i mean this is i'm sorry i i did not ask
you to revisit that
okay all right just the documentation
okay
that one was not on the table which are
not in any other list okay gives the
elements for each
okay fine
okay should it be unique
elements list or each unique elements i
mean i know danny will kill me for
change opening that camera yeah unique
element list of lists of sub-lists
inside lists
but does it doesn't this only work at
level one isn't that part of the point
i
can't answer that i haven't tried i
suppose elements could be lists
right but but it's still looking at them
right each element is looking at
elements at level one yes
and no you cannot add a level spec
how do how would people feel about a
name like that
lists unique elements i just worry that
unique elements
plopped out of the blue
it's kind of an obscure name
maybe we should call it you know
list intersection or something
all right
no it's not
but
i i'm just saying like like there are
tons of functions that operate on lists
start them all with lists
well fair enough crystal what do you
think about the name unique elements are
you okay with it yeah i think it seems
it seems fine i mean it seems similar to
what are the other functions we have
like
count wait wait this is called count
distinct
which is slightly different but um
but i can never remember the name count
distinct anyway um
yeah i mean one thing is
if we think too hard about this we're
going to get back to all compliments
which had already been rejected
it seems like we have so many
duplicates we have distinct we have
unique we have so many different terms
for the this concept
you know i mean
which is which right although i think
that's a different issue from the fact
that you know all the ones we have right
now are sort of
operating on one list and right you're
giving me the distinct elements of this
list you're deleting the duplicates in
this list
and this one is not acting on the list
it's acting on a list of lists
all right that's true yeah unique
elements actually you know that that's i
didn't i didn't realize that point
unique elements sounds like it does what
delete duplicates does yes right right
which is why i'm suggesting lists of
plural unique elements
so so this is the discussion we had last
time in which we were considering
whether this should be var because for
example symmetric element
geometric difference sorry is for arc
well this one really can't be though
because i mean you it has that structure
issue of
um
recapitulating the input structure
so your argument is that it has the same
input structure as output structure
yes
it might be a little weird to give uh to
give a you know a sequence of uh
of arguments in and then get out and
then now i agree i think it's a pruner
it's basically a pruner that prunes down
to the single unique element in each
list right
yes but then that makes it have this
additional level of list that makes it
difficult to name
well except i don't think that
i i i i disagree with that
uh
analysis right i think what makes a
difficult uh name is that it implicitly
uses it right is that it has multiple
lists in it whether you pack them in a
list or call it var arg as opposed to
the other things where we talk about
unique elements in which
you only have one list no matter how you
look at it right
like count accounts and things like that
right
what do people think about lists unique
elements
it sounds very awkward
yeah you i mean uniques elements list
sounds better to me i'm not sure
necessarily the wrong thing
it that two plurals is reminiscent of
john's hopkins
which i think was also a mistake
why is it called that was that person
called john i assume it's his name
a single person's name yeah i'm guessing
really no
that's
four people two of each i don't know
do you know that uh so it's so johns
hopkins is a single individual whose
first name is john's
and last name is hopkins that was my
guess
wow
and although apparently after his great
grandmother
margaret johns
ah
okay
i was thinking there might be a st in
there somewhere originally but
which i won't even try to pronounce not
being of the right nationality
but
it almost makes me remember the trivia
of allison wesley publishing company
where it was started by two unrelated
people both with last name cummings
and they used their little names as the
as the uh
thing for the company at least that's
what i was told by their executives many
years ago long before they were long
before the web existed and before you
could check statements
um
okay
in any case back to this
yeah i mean
i guess one question is uh is the
documentation with the usage etc okay
modulo possible name change yes i think
the documentation is fine okay
why don't we use captions for those
examples
sure
yeah no the examples are are not
complete but um jose and i wanted to be
sure
that we had the rest pinned down
correctly before proceeding okay what is
this thing really this says
those elements
you're pruning down
to those elements
that don't appear in any other list
right so each list gets reduced to the
things that only appear in it and no
other lists
now like select unique
no because select usually has all kinds
of stuff in it it's the same problem
the original name was all compliments
this could be multi-complement or
something like that
that's incomprehensible i have to think
about complement every time i use
complement i have to think oh we start
with the universal set and then we
subtract the other stuff
it always takes me at least at least me
a moment to think through how that works
um
i mean it's really a what would people
use this for it's a pruner
and the case i always use it for is i'm
updating the list of units that are in
wolfram language and i want to know
which ones appeared and which ones
disappeared
and so i need to know which ones are
unique to my starting list
or unique to each revision
it's sort of like the disjoint i mean i
guess that's another thing we talked
about last time which is the disjoint
uh whatever
what's it called destroying union
something like that
yeah yeah that's the symmetric
difference i think is this metric
you don't want to get too much into that
analogy yeah because
of the in out
even odd whatever parody
which this does not have
i use a function right in the sense this
is simpler than complements because all
the lists are treated symmetrically
which is not the case of our complement
function correct right
right correct
i mean this is actually a useful
function i mean in that
in the what's new what's old what's
coming in what's going out it's like the
diffs
right
if you want to compare several
lists this is very useful because you
know who is responsible for having too
many elements or too few elements
well maybe the name is okay
maybe we should just call it differences
whoops we have that don't we yes we do
thank you
but it isn't really
all right i'm not coming up with
anything better and this is probably
what we went around last time so let's
assume we're at the best point can we
make an experimental for this version
just in case we have a name disaster
yeah we certainly take it as
experimental
okay
delete elements what do we we i'm sorry
we're just tagging it as experimental or
not putting it in experimental context
no no no we're just typing anything
ghastly okay fine well nothing ghastly
it's absolutely lovely
um delete elements what's the question
here do we one two or three a's what is
the specification of delete elements
here yeah so there's a multiplicity
specification
that that input is showing where it's
saying
up to n instances of whatever yes yeah
in this case
jose proposed that that that case would
delete three and i
i endorse that
i think that's fine i think it's the
most stable because otherwise you have
to analyze
i think it's fine i think if i then
change one of those
yes i think it's fine okay that's what
we'll go with
i think that's actually what we have
currently implemented
okay let's have a very very quick look
at this and i really want to see the xml
versions of this kind of thing
but this is the first special purpose
trio
still not looking very good
yeah so the first point is basically
that
um
the
labels being the full pile file pads get
very crowded very quickly well i i think
this is the wrong way around anyway i
think this tree should be left
you know that these trees should be
arranged so that they are
not
like this i think i think nobody wants a
file system thing this way it's amusing
but it's not what you want you want the
tree to by default go left to right
don't you
need to press it with if if you have a
prototype you can see what that looks
like tree layout goes to left
why is this prototype build not coming
to life
because it takes forever to launch docky
tools in the prototype
not and do tree layout goes to left
and that's certainly not the world's
most impressive layout
bluff
this is horrifying
i didn't know if i say unless this
and this is
oh you just have a very long leading
uh okay
this is funky what's that seven what's
that doing now
when you have more than
i think ten nodes
but but that's a really ugly thing it's
never been designed has it
has that been designed
no
that's really bad if i might say so
and also
has a special edge to it
why is tree layout arrow left not an
option for unlabeled tree
options aren't uh implemented from label
tree yet
okay
look listen wait a minute that that
bracket seven thing that needs design
okay
but also is it intentional that the edge
pointing to it is different
it looks like a bug yeah
and i think we'd want them synced up
a little better
but the edge or that but we also have an
appearance here and this right now is
just a labeled node with a weird
you know angle bracket seven those angle
brackets are from like terminals
you know
34 years there's also no way to style
that technically they're not right i
mean that that's
a named character called skeleton
yes okay fair enough they are
modernization of what happened on
terminals
so what were you saying um there need to
be two cases for the unlabeled and
labeled one might need to look a little
bit different for the unlabeled case
yes hey did you have any chance to to go
through the the recoloring of the of the
those things can we look at that before
we end this meeting uh yeah let me
do you want to share or is it i can send
it
okay then we have to wrap here
this is uh
might be rough didn't have ian's expert
hands look at it first so
he's been very helpful to this whole
process of understanding
how do i just
pull it into
maybe the old yep
so
on the right there's sort of two
kind of cases there's the sort of
darker just has a
black and you know one one's darker and
one's lighter around the uh labeled
leaves
well if it's implementable i mean i
would say that the somewhat lighter one
is better
okay
the unlabeled ones
are a bit
too weighty compared to the labeled ones
yeah i don't know yeah yeah
yes they probably are
but that's a question of whether ian is
able to implement
a i mean we could try going a little bit
lighter with these notes
okay
but you'll probably be okay here can you
try that just try one one iteration of
going a little lighter
yeah
if you want i can share
yeah
ready
yep
you know you could do this without
technology it would be it's
quite easy
but
yeah it's
yeah okay anyway there was the
ian it helped make that notebook help
make this notebook um and it does have
some of that stuff in there okay
okay i think that looks quite nice what
you've got there now let's see if we
apply that
over to the
that's at a hundred percent
so wait a minute i should be looking at
the top one over on the right is that
correct yeah
i think it looks pretty decent
christopher what do you think in terms
of the relative weighting of other
people relative weighting
of the label than unlabeled nodes
they're sort of okay i think
i could also export it
real quick and you could look at it on
your screen that doesn't matter it's
going to look the same it's just bits
other people's comments here
finally
well
i mean it may be a little heavy for pure
i'm sorry what
i said it looks fine to me um except i
wouldn't have filled the nodes but
yeah i mean what what is the
would it be possible to see what the the
current
stuff looks like with normal trees yeah
yeah send this to me
you know they're just
unsure
okay yep
the um
for some reason the rectangle around the
two doesn't look quite right maybe the
sizing isn't quite matched right now but
something's bothering me about the two
um
yeah the scales might be a little bit
off in my in my um
in my mock
i mean other other than that looks
pretty good to me
okay the issue is going to be an
ordinary tree
okay so let's say i just say random tree
of um
30. see i think that's going to look bad
if we thicken up all of those
can we can we easily do that can we
thicken up all those borders
yeah do tree element style
all goes to
[Music]
edge form
[Music]
telly what is the edge full
uh what's what's the rgb value or
something
four six
or no four eight six six four eight
what the hell is that
the origin he's giving you hex
so rgb color string
what is it what do we call it rgb color
rgb color and then the string
that's not too bad
it's better than i expected
looks pretty good to me
i like it
let's go with it now the only question
is for
for a label tree
should we just have these be empty boxes
and i think the answer may be yes that
may be just fine
perhaps that's the best way to do it
okay and then filled for the unlabeled
tree
presumably
let's see if you can send us out a milk
go ahead
no i was just saying i i agree with that
i think
you know
having a bunch of empty squares
everywhere seems a bit silly so i like
the the solid there but
if you have there having you know
nothing seeing nothingness it's like oh
that one doesn't have a label that makes
sense
right you know you know what the big
difference is because in the case of
unlabeled tree there may be very big
ones
right so so if i say
oops this is i need to go over here for
the unlabeled tree
wait a minute how do i get the new
styling
ian how do i get the new styling the
code is in the agenda notebook
oh i see can i just run this no but it
isn't working here
oh because i don't have unless
yeah so just go to the example and right
make that 100 right
this example here yeah right just
evaluate options one in place
what
oh this needs to be in a prototype sorry
this code here
in the prototype build
okay now
i go this to this
okay
yeah that's much better we don't want
some crazy thing with what about the
aspect ratio of this creature
is that right do we think
this looks much better i mean the the
concept of of this being a
you could specify aspect ratio
well i know i could specify but what do
we think is the right aspect ratio
what's determining the aspect ratio
right now
default graph aspect ratio okay what
which is what charles
[Music]
well assuming it's sticking to graphics
right that's one number is
or is there no but it's obviously not
it's obviously not
so the question for charles is what is
the aspect ratio of a graph by default
because it's not
it does something intelligent
um but i need to think about it i don't
remember what we did at the time i i
remember talking to you about it at
length we came up with something
right that the default is automatic but
that's not what automatic means in
visualization functions right because in
visualization functions it means
take it from the plot range right the
deuce
make the aspect ratio match the ratios
of the
yeah yeah right right exactly which is
not what this does this is doing
something based on i mean and so so we
haven't even thought about what the
aspect ratio for this so this thing here
basically you're saying i want to be
able to take this is that a graphics
you've just made this into a graphic so
we can just say graphics
aspect ratio arrow one
what the heck
is this not a graphics
no that's a bug in the prototype build
okay it's a tree okay so if i say tree
i think that looks somewhat better than
this
um
i don't know i i think these these
shallower aspect ratios look better
comments from people
look for a tree
there is clearly a
okay give me a sense of this there is
the tree depth which is the number of
levels right
yep
and there is what is the tree breadth
that is the number of what what
determines that
what determines how wide these things
are is it the
the maximum number of
it's like the maximum length of a level
is it just at one level i mean if you
but but does it reuse the slots
in a vertical in a vertical slice it
appears to reuse the slots you can see
some places where it does
i think
okay
so ian can you say that it's reusing the
slots for the embedding
yes i'm not sure well who knows that
what do you mean by a regime the sloth
what i mean is
that
i mean it obviously is right because
this thing this node here
okay
a given node
what am i trying to say if you look at
the horizontal position of a node
yeah it reuses the particular horizontal
position many times
you can see an example where it
definitely does sort of in the to the
right a bit
okay there's right where you're to the
right of where your mouse is well that
one then that one
down there and then there's an example
to the right of that that's even more
extreme okay where the fan overlaps the
other fan yes
right
okay
so
well
okay so the question really is
there's a certain maximum width
which is not completely obvious to me
what's what determines it i don't think
it's the number of distinct things on a
given level i think it's more subtle
than that i i think that depends on the
embedding
look we've got our particular embedding
i'm asking for this default embedding
we've got a certain width
which is
i mean the the nodes are equally spaced
in x coordinates
in whatever that choice of embedding is
and they are also equally spaced in y
coordinates so the question is given
you know maximum x extent and maximum y
extent aka depth
what should the aspect ratio be
did you get the question
do you understand what's that
so you want you want to
determine the aspect ratio based on the
depth and it's called the width of the
graph
right
we know the width of the graph the width
of the graph in x units we know and the
the depth the height of the graph and y
units we know
we've just got two numbers and we've got
to determine given those two numbers
what shape do you want the graph to be
so here's an example what we could do we
could say we want the opening angle of
the trees to be x
right we want the minimum opening angle
there's always going to be given the x x
positions and y positions the minimum
opening angle
is that arc tangent of you know
uh min x
min delta y over min delta x
is that correct
do you see what i'm saying
yes sure but
but what i was just essentially thinking
is you know what two is using that you
just using a
layered
layout which is more based on an
optimization
problem so we
essentially we pose it as a you know
linear constraint optimizations
where we don't actually take into
account those additional information
but i know but the aspect ratio is
determined after the fact isn't it
no actually if i remember correctly so
the fact of i mean the way we adjust
the the
the coordinates
right we essentially are
when we solve the optimization problem
we readjust the coordinates so that we
get the appropriate aspect ratio
automatically without changing it
i see
but what is the appropriate aspect ratio
you don't know
the spot i don't remember the dimensions
we need to look at this because i don't
think these trees i think these trees
should be flatter
i think
anybody else got an opinion about that
but if i mean wait wait wait wait wait
wait i just want to know do people think
that tree looks good or do they think
this tree looks better
i mean
the first one
the first one
yeah i think the first well okay that's
what we have right now
i have the impression that there is some
sort of square grid behind this and
we tend to believe that the squares
should be square not rectangles
fine well if we think the first one
looks better anyway then we don't have a
problem
i mean that's the default that's what we
have right now so even if it's shrouded
in antiquity and mystery
why it is that way
we're we're still we're good
that doesn't look bad
now by the way just notice that if we
tried to do this with labels we'd be
absolutely dead in the water
that's pretty nice looking
do people agree i mean
yep
i mean we optimized the full layout to
work nicely so
it went to several tests so yeah
well it's good all right so we can just
declare victory there
so this means i mean how big can i go
here do you think
if i go a thousand node random tree
what's taking time is it the layout or
is it the oh that's quite lovely
i think random trees slower than the
layout
try to get the measure correct
but i think it's lovely looks great
all right we declare victory okay
anything else we need to figure out
really late for all the stuff
nope i think that was
the main slate of things that we're
gonna look at today excellent
okay thanks all